Britain and the Netherlands claimed a
foiled cyberattacks by Russia and
international groups have been quick to
join the accusations
the EU has already expressed its concern
along with NATO Chiefs er operation
targeting the organisation for the
prohibition prohibition of chemical
weapons
today's announcement by the Dutch and
British governments have exposed
Russia's indiscriminate campaign of
cyber attacks around the world Russia
must stop this reckless pattern of
behavior the Russian government needs to
know that if they flout international
law in this way there will be
consequences they will be exposed live
now to paly Boyka in London with the
details Polly what is Russia accused of
now well investigators in The Hague
today said that the four Russians that
had recently been expelled from the
Netherlands were in fact hackers with
the GRU that's Russia's military
intelligence agency and the allegations
excuse me related to a plot that was
orchestrated back in April which is
notably they said the the time when the
investigation into the poisoning of
Sergey and Yulia scrapple was taking
place and these hackers allegedly were
attempting to hack into the OPCW and the
laptops that they seized from them from
the group had been used in Brazil
Switzerland and Malaysia previously -
that and investigators provided images
of these four alleged GRU agents they
say that they had diplomatic passports
among them there was an IT expert in a
support agency they'd hired a car and
they were scouting locations from where
to conduct this alleged hack and the
British ambassador to the Netherlands
also elaborated there and he said that
in the wake of this poisoning
the GRU attempted to hack Porton Down
which is the UK's
military research lab they also
attempted to hack apparently the UK
Foreign Office and one of the C's
laptops contained also attempt to hack
into the investigation into the downing
of flight mh17 so revelations or
allegations as the russians refer to
them from the dutch and the british
appear to have been coordinated today
and the uk's military defense secretary
had some harsh words for moscow as well
take a listen to what he had to say this
is not the actions of a great power this
is a reaction of a pariah state and will
continue working with allies to isolate
them and make them understand they
cannot continue to conduct themselves in
such a way that was gavin williamson
they're speaking in brussels at a
meeting with his US counterpart US
secretary for defense Jim mattis and
NATO defence ministers and the harsh
rhetoric all comes off the back of a
statement released by British
authorities overnight where they say
that the UK government's cyber national
cyber security center has identified
that the GRU Russian military
intelligence is behind a string of major
cyber attacks that have taken place
actually cyberattacks that we have all
heard of the big cyber attack against
wadda that's the world anti-doping
agency they say that happened amidst the
Russian doping scandal they say that the
GRU is also behind the dnc raids that's
those leaked Clinton emails in the
run-up to the election of Donald Trump
over in the US and also they alleged
that the GRU is behind attacks against
Ukrainian and Russian businesses and
transport infrastructure and also a hack
against a small UK TV station so this UK
cyber agency says it assessed with high
confidence that the GRU was almost
certainly behind all those attacks and
some of the hacks that have been
attributed to Russian groups in the past
fancy bears porn storm some of these
hacking groups but now the
government is saying that these groups
are all directly linked to the gr use
hacking apparatus and that it's orders
come directly from Vladimir Putin's
Kremlin and interesting that they even
accused the GRU of hacking Russian
businesses and Russian citizens as well
now the Russian Foreign Ministry
spokesperson has been speaking this
morning and she's already reacted to
this plethora of accusations with some
rather strong words of her own by
labeling them depending on how you
translate it from Russian a diabolical
cocktail of accusations take a listen to
what she had to say was bought off
everything is being mixed
indiscriminately as if in a bottle of
nina ricci perfume Russian military
intelligence cyber spies Kremlin hackers
vaada it's all just one big witches brew
the imagination of our British
colleagues knows no limits who could
come up with all this I'd like to take a
look at this Hans Christian Andersen's
the Russian embassy in London has also
weighed in saying that these accusations
are crude disinformation and also just
to finish off on the top diplomat for
Russia in the Netherlands the charged
affair for Russia there has been
summoned to the Dutch Foreign Ministry
for what is no doubt going to be a
pretty uncomfortable chat
you